[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de le
journal de tv 78 l'actualité locale en
26 minutes les titres de ce mardi 17
septembre une réunion publique hier à
magny les hameaux le député jean noël
barrot invitait les habitants une
réflexion sur l'économie circulaire et
le gaspillage alimentaire l'objectif
alimenter le projet de loi présenté la
semaine prochaine au sénat reconnecter
villes et campagnes par téléphone c'est
le souhait du collectif
ici la terre ce jeudi il lance un numéro
d'appel gratuit a pour tout les urbains
ils pourront imposer en direct leurs
questions sur les réalités du métier
d'agriculteur et de ses pratiques
et puis ce service de la région
ile-de-france permet dé location longue
durée de vélos électriques vélio est
désormais disponible à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'offre a été
lancé officiellement aujourd'hui en
pleine semaine européenne de la mobilité
à suivre dans ce journal également des
anniversaires 80 ans pour le cnrs dix
ans pour l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
le député des yvelines jean noël barrot
organisait ce lundi à 16 septembre une
réunion publique à magny les hameaux le
thème de ce rendez vous le projet de loi
pour une économie circulaire et pour la
lutte contre le gaspillage une centaine
de personnes représentant et
d'associations élus ou chefs
d'entreprises ont participé aux échanges
nicolas landry créer un indice de
réparabilité d'objets généraliser le
logo trimane limiter le gaspillage des
invendus non alimentaires ou favoriser
la consigne plusieurs dispositions
inscrites dans le projet de loi relatifs
à la lutte contre le gaspillage et à
l'économie circulaire le sujet abordé ce
lundi 7 septembre dans une réunion
publique organisée par le député jean
noël barrot
je crois que c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe beaucoup les gens les jeunes
d'ailleurs mais toute la société en
général qui qui souhaitent évoluer se
donner des modes de consommation qui
sont plus respectueux de l'environnement
et qui sont plus durables et ça explique
l' enthousiasme qu'on a pu voir ce soir
parmi les participants des citoyens des
élus des représentants d'associations
mais aussi des dirigeants d'entreprise
acteurs de l'économie circulaire
c'est le cas de pascal guillot
directrice générale de nouvelles
attitudes
cette société basée à buc est
spécialisée dans la collecte et le tri
de papier auprès d'entreprises avec une
redistribution à l'industrie papetière
en charge du recyclage
on prend sept ans prend une matière mais
qui est déjà utilisée utilisez donc on
réutilise la matière en produits et
lorsqu'on a consommé on essaye de
réutiliser la matière c'est ça
l'économie circulaire
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre de la transition écologique
brune poirson devait participer à ce
rendez vous elle a été retenu par une
réunion avec la sénatrice l'est
républicain martha de sidrac rapporteur
du texte
comme tout projet de loi il y aura des
discussions animées entre le sénat et le
gouvernement comme entre l'assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement précisément
parce que c'est un sujet majeur qui
préoccupe tellement les français début
des discussions sur ce texte de loi la
semaine prochaine pour une première
lecture au sénat avec moi en plateau
trois invités agriculteurs dans les
yvelines membres du collectif ici la
terre fanny à boschung éleveuse de
vaches laitières arrosait olivier
couprie agriculteurs à montfort l'amaury
et jérôme regnault agriculteurs à
plaisir bonsoir à vous trois bon ça
merci de votre présence je vous fais
juste réagir sur ce sujet le
gouvernement qui prépare une loi contre
le gaspillage alimentaire favoriser
aussi l'économie circulaire c'est une
thématique à laquelle vous êtes
sensibles voix agriculteurs oui c'est
une thématique complémentaire à un petit
peu ce qu'on va vous proposer c'est à
dire que ça fait partie des sujets
sociétal d'aujourd'hui nous on avance un
petit peu sur ce qui en qualité dans
l'assiette je comprends que les gens se
préoccupent aussi de ski en quantité et
donc le non-gaspillage va aussi avec
avoir les moyens de se payer de
meilleure qualité mais il ya un lien
avec ce dont vous êtes venu me parler ce
pour être peut être l'un des sujets
intérêt une des thématiques abordées via
votre numéro d'appel gratuit un numéro
vert que vous lancer officiellement ce
jeudi et qui permettra aux habitants des
villes ou aux urbains de dialoguer en
direct avec des agriculteurs sur leur
métier sur leurs pratiques aussi déjà
pourquoi l'on sait ce numéro est ce
qu'il ya un contexte particulier on
pense forcément à l'agriculture qui
souffre peut-être de stéréotypes
malvenue aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qu'on prépare depuis
maintenant six mois beaucoup de réunions
en sorte qu'on a décidé de se lancer
mais qui est bout énormément d'actualité
avec cette rentrée en fait tout
simplement fanny et ans éleveuse en
circuit court avait un contact
commercial
de proximité avec le grand public
olivier faisant beaucoup d'accueil sur
son exploitation notamment accueilli
pension de chevaux et vend deux fois
pour des centres hippiques et moi même
engagé sur des le monde associatif sur
la plaine de versailles on avait trois
contacts différents être le grand public
et on ressentait avec ses trois volets
différents la même chose c'est-à-dire
que si l'agriculture a parfois une image
difficile
l'agriculteur lui a une image positive
pour autant qu'on ait tant de pouvoir
converser ensemble et vous avez parlé de
ces sujets en cette rentrée on pense
forcément aux pesticides l'utilisation
des pesticides qui donne peut-être une
mauvaise image des agriculteurs l'idée
c'est oui de reconnecter de recréer du
lien et qui est important on l'a senti
et évidemment ça va être ça va être en
fait de pouvoir mettre en rapport
directement un professionnel avec
quelqu'un qui se posera ses questions
d'acquis d'inquiétude et pouvoir dire
comment nous agriculteurs on vit ces
choses là et répondre à toutes ces peurs
sociétal qui sont qui sont justifiées
quelque part avec tout ce qu'on entend
mais qui demande une réponse d'un
professionnel alors on donne pas le
numéro encore en dessous qui sera lancé
officiellement ce jeudi on vous relaiera
bien sûr l'information sur notre antenne
vous parliez des objectifs oui c'est
vraiment de reconnecter un villes et
campagnes c'est ça olivier oui
exactement
c'est ce lien qu'on peut avoir en
croisant nos voisins quand on travaille
dans nos champs ou dans nos prairies
on sent que nos voisins ont besoin de
savoir ce qu'on fait comprendre ce qu'on
fait et dès qu'on discute avec eux les
choses s'apaisent parce qu'il ya une
certaine crispation en ce moment et on
veut limiter cette crispation et une
fois qu'on a expliqué comment travailler
qu'elles soient en apporter à nos
animaux qu'elle soit importante à nos
plantes avec quelle sécurité
on travaillait pour le consommateur qui
sont nos clients qui nous font vivre les
gens sont tout de suite rassuré et ils
achètent nos produits notamment les bons
produits de fanny apprendre à vous
connaître c'est quoi finalement lors la
question est large être agriculteur
aujourd'hui pas vraiment apprendre à
nous connaître c'est plutôt rétablir
brun
le dialogue entre le citoyen et
l'agriculteur rétablir la vérité parce
qu on entend plein de choses sur les
médias sont toujours un peu d'effort
mais là c'est vraiment l'idée vous avez
des questions à poser les directement un
agriculteur je ne mens pas
d'intermédiaires ligne dure
intermédiaire c'est vraiment un réseau
de plus de 150 agriculteurs qui vont
répondre en direct au téléphone sur leur
temps de travail dans le tracteur avec
leurs animaux est vraiment répondre à
toutes les questions que les gens se
posent quoi parlait aussi de vos
pratiques elles évoluent ces pratiques
forcément avec le temps je pense à votre
cas jérôme mourinho vous utiliser la
technologie aujourd'hui des données gps
et ça pour travailler vos champs oui je
suis engagé personnellement en
agriculture de précision
c'est à dire ça pourrait se résumer en
disant faire la bonne intervention au
bon moment et à la bonne dose donc bien
sûr le moins d'impact possible j'ai
choisi de m'engager dans cette voie là
et ça va être un petit peu cet éventail
de toute l'agriculture française qui va
pouvoir être témoignée au par cette
ligne
chacun donnera sa réalité rappeler que
nous sommes des professionnels conforter
les gens sur le fait qu'ils sont très
belles années que dans l'agriculture par
deux en france avec des passionnés au
bout de la ligne
et concrètement comment ça va ça va
fonctionner ce numéro vert alors une
permanence téléphonique qui va
s'organiser donc à partir de jeudi midi
donc de 12 heures à 18 heures qui sera
exercée du mardi au samedi par une
centaine d'agriculteurs qui vont se
relayer tout au long de ces journées
pour voir écouter répondre aux questions
et éventuellement faire venir sur nos
fermes si le besoin s'en fait sentir
montrer nos pratiques en toute
transparence parce que ce qu'on fait on
aime le faire et on fait bien depuis
longtemps et qui va assurer c'est
justement ces permanences et vous 3 il
ya un réseau un peu plus gros derrière
vous on espère qu'il y en a d'autres et
on espère qu'il y en a d'autres à notre
réseau d'amitiés nos connaissances nos
anciens amis d'école voilà on a recruté
différents différents agriculteurs des
vrais professionnels pour pouvoir
répondre à ces questions pour ne pas
assumer à 3 cette lourde mais les tâches
qui est de communiquer sur la boutique
ça a été très motivante si vous voulez
parce que sur les 130 agriculteurs dont
105 qui déjà répond plus 25 ans réserve
s'il succès et à notre rencontre nous
n'avons eu aucun refus et à chaque fois
les gens étaient motivés et on a pu avec
le grand nombre de participants pouvoir
proposer des spécialisées c'est-à-dire
maraîchers arboriculteurs évidemment des
céréaliers évidemment des éleveurs des
polyculteur avec toutes formes
d'agriculture donc il y aura des
conventionnels il y aura l'agriculture
de précision ou de conservation comme
arrivé il y aura du bio etc
ils vont témoigner vraiment en direct de
leur ressenti de leur quotidien et
j'espère qu'il y aura des questions
d'inquiétude des ces interrogations
peut-être un peu de défouloir mais aussi
beaucoup d'appels pour un peu réconforté
une profession qui en ce moment et dans
le mal est vis-à-vis de l'ue regard
qu'on pose sur elle alors que c'est
vraiment une profession passion qui
donne beaucoup de choses vis-à-vis de ce
qu'on apporte on a une belle belle
agriculture enjeu pour avoir un soutien
on peut d'ailleurs soutenir votre
initiative ya une cagnotte litchi qui
est en ligne le lien s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci à vous trois ans rappelle
que le numéro d'appel est lancée ce
jeudi et autour de la table on avait
donc fanny boschung olivier couprie et
jérôme regnault merci d'avoir été avec
nous en plateau politique locale
à présent il ne sera pas candidat pour
un troisième mandat à villepreux
stéphane mirambeau ne se représentera
pas aux élections municipales de 2020 le
maire de la commune qui revient tout
juste aux affaires après cette remise en
retrait en juillet l'a confirmé cette
semaine une majorité municipale au bord
de l'implosion et des accusations de
harcèlement sexuel par deux femmes ont
motivé la décision de l'élu la semaine
dernière thiriez sling premier adjoint
et valérie fernandez 6e adjointe avait
démissionné de leurs postes
stéphane denis rambaud qui indique tout
de même vouloir aller jusqu'à la fin de
son mandat les élections municipales
elles sont programmées en mars 2020 à
l'occasion de la semaine de la mobilité
vélio s'installe dans l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise à la sortie de la gare
de montigny le bretonneux ces vélos
électriques sont désormais à votre
disposition le lan
on se dérouler aujourd'hui et les
précisions avec ce sujet et de mathilde
mignier de margaux du roi le vélo
électrique vélio prend place sur le
territoire notamment à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines où une station a été
aménagé des futurs usagers qui
découvrent ces vélos bleu toutes
équipées avant d'arriver je pensais pas
trop parce que j'ai des enfants est
souvent le problème c est ce que je peux
mettre un enfant sur nos vélos au pain
effectivement au moment de la
présentation de mon indiqué la
possibilité de bêtes en ciel où c'est
très bien pensé
c'est très bien il est assez facile il
est assez simple parce que voilà il ya
trois vitesses pour le mode électrique
et
donc très bien on peut le mettre en vélo
en fonction à la reine vélo complètement
normal et vélos électriques pour 40
euros par mois et une caution de 400
euros
un bébé go étaient attribués pendant six
mois un usager pour le stationnement il
peut ramener son vélo chez lui dans une
station vélib go ou le laisser dehors
mais risqué de se le faire voler si vous
avez un pavillon vous pouvez avoir la
chance de garder votre vélo facilement
voir une cave
mais quand vous êtes en collectif c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et que dans les
collectifs déjà même les vélos
électriques se font parfois volé et
settat et 7 à frein du coup au
développement du vélo pour tout le monde
en attendant des locaux à vélo plus
sécurisé pour éviter tout risque de
casse et de vol
les pistes cyclables pourront être
prises d'assaut par ces nouveaux vélos
électriques qui ne demande qu'à rouler
et à l'occasion de la semaine européenne
des mobilités à des tarifs spéciaux sont
mises en place à la vélostation juste à
côté de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'à dimanche 3 et des
abonnements de ce service de location de
cycles sont à prix cassés jusqu'à -70%
saint quentin en yvelines va amener
également auprès des entreprises du
territoire des forums va organiser à des
forums de la mobilité cette semaine le
but c'est d'informer sur les bonnes
pratiques et promouvoir une mobilité
plus durable pour les salariés qui
habitent dans deux tiers des cas en
dehors de l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise
on a encore de façon majoritaire des
salariés qui viennent sur leur lieu de
travail en voiture mais surtout
l'agglomération à développer et à
renforcer tout son réseau de bus nous
avons la chance sur le territoire
d'avoir 7
gare et de ces gars il faut pouvoir
rejoindre directement son lieu de
travail
et puis enfin et c'est une tendance très
forte que l'on voit depuis maintenant
plusieurs années c'est ce qu'on appelle
les mobilités douces donc en particulier
le vélo des propos recueillis par
nicolas landry un tour de france pour
lever des fonds c'est l' aventure dans
laquelle s'est lancé une start-up saint
quentinois 6 kg aux lancers ira beauvais
le fondateur hervé mation et son équipe
vont parcourir quatre mille kilomètres
et traverser 23 villes partout en france
pour présenter leurs produits c'est une
cabine de détente
le périple se terminera début décembre à
saint quentin en yvelines une idée
novatrice pour cette start up qui est
installée au sein du ski cube interview
collecter une nouvelle fois par nicolas
landry
on a réservé 10000 places dans des
cinémas pour et créer un spectacle
s'appelle une heure pour vous convaincre
pour aller chercher chaque français
pendant une heure et leur donner la
dimension de notre projet est allé faire
une levée de fonds en crampons ndinga en
réalise bien sûr la levée de fonds est
importante mais c'est aussi donner toute
la dimension sociale de ce projet à
chaque personne peut mettre à partir de
50 euros
c'était une volonté aussi que qu'on
avait c'était de permettre à monsieur
madame tout le monde de pouvoir rentrer
dans du crowdfunding sur le site on met
on mais quand on est à la recherche de
deux cent cinquante mille euros mais on
espère bien entendu beaucoup plus on
aimerait viser les cinq cent mille euros
le téléthon en 2019 et au programme les
6 et 7 décembre prochain mais dans les
yvelines on a décidé de le lancer dès le
week-end dernier une journée festive a
été organisé à l'aérodrome de acharné
villepreux le reportage de marie l'ania
piccino et de patrick jacques de dixmude
un défi logo réussi pour le téléthon de
villepreux
plus de 120 personnes ont recréé le
fameux logo de l'association
une image forte pour le lancement
départemental du téléthon sous le thème
de la hauteur à l'aérodrome de chavenay
villepreux aujourd'hui on a essayé de
faire plein de surprises des belles
surprises sur le thème de la hauteur
donc là vous voyez on est entouré
d'avion et c'est merveilleux d'être
accueilli dans un endroit pareil qui
illustre complètement le thème parmi les
multiples animations un simulateur de
vol où les participants pouvaient
voyager aux commandes de leur propre
avion tu es là san francisco je suis
allé à new york
allez c'était génial j'ai fait un voyage
fabuleux
j'ai pris de la hauteur donc pour
aujourd'hui c'était génial c'était
vraiment dentelle un lancement de la
campagne en septembre avant le téléthon
2010 9 des 6 et 7 décembre
deux cent cinquante mille bénévoles se
relaieront pendant 30 heures pour la
recherche contre les maladies rares la
réussite du téléthon tient à la
mobilisation de centaines de milliers de
bénévoles partout en france
et évidemment chacun d'entre eux a
besoin de temps pour organiser son
animation pour rassembler les gens
autour d'eux pour convaincre les
participants et d'autres associations à
les rejoindre dans cette belle aventure
l'ensemble des bénévoles depuis plus de
30 ans l'afm téléthon remportent des
victoires thérapeutique grâce aux dons
récoltés est consacrée à la recherche
dernière grande source d'espoir la
thérapie génique
les traités de paix peuvent-ils garantir
la paix la question a été soulevée lors
d'une table ronde organisée par la
maison de l'europe des yvelines au
théâtre alexandre dumas c'est à saint
germain en laye événement à l'occasion
des centenaires de deux traités signés
en 1919 dans le département traité de
versailles avec l'allemagne et de saint
germain en laye avec l'autriche hongrie
à des documents adoptés en apparence
mais qui jetèrent en fait être les bases
de la seconde guerre mondiale les débats
ont été faits en présence notamment des
ambassadeurs de tchécoslovaquie de
hongrie pardon et de république tchèque
à paris d'ailleurs le rôle de ces
diplomates a changé 1 depuis lé deux
conflits mondiaux écouter l'ancien
ambassadeur de france à l'unesco au
micro du go casadamont de nos confrères
de radio sensations
il est certain que les diplomates que le
rôle des diplomates a profondément
changé ces dernières décennies et qu' il
est très différent de ce qu'il était au
moment de la première guerre mondiale ou
au moment de la seconde guerre mondiale
au fond le rôle des diplomates c'est à
la fois renforcer diversifiée mais qu'il
n'est plus le rôle de représentation
d'un pouvoir politique auprès d'un autre
pouvoir politique qu'il était en 1920 ou
même d'ailleurs encore en 1950
aujourd'hui comme je dis on est autant
l'ambassadeur des français que
l'ambassadeur de france quand on est à
l'étranger ou auprès d'une organisation
internationale et retrouver une série
d'interviews sur le sujet sur la page
facebook de la maison de l'europe des
yvelines il ya 80 ans naissait le cnrs
centre national de la recherche
scientifique un anniversaire fêté face à
l'univers c'était le nom de cet
événement proposé par l'organisme public
sur son site de gif-sur-yvette dans le
plateau de saclay sur le plateau de
saclay ce samedi à dimanche dernier on
revient sur cet événement avec maman
varaldo
partez pour une immersion dans la
recherche spatiale le cnrs organisme
national multidisciplinaire qui couvre
tous les domaines scientifiques fête ses
80 ans
l'exposition face à l'univers s'est
déroulée à gif-sur-yvette dans le
château du cnrs acquis en 1946 soit neuf
ans après la création du centre national
des recherches scientifiques
cette exposition est inédite parce
qu'elle elle elle rassemble une
trentaine d'instruments 30 instruments
spatiaux qui ont été développés dans les
laboratoires franciliens
le public pouvait échanger avec 75
astrophysiciens planétologues et
ingénieurs en instrumentation spatiale
les instruments d'exploration des
planètes étaient visibles ainsi que leur
évolution dans le temps
comme cet instrument spatiale microméga
à un microscope qui est le petit fils de
mes gars ces instruments servent à faire
donc une image d'une surface planétaire
d'un échantillon à toutes les couleurs
de la lumière dans un domaine spectral
du visible et de l'infrarouge d'autres
instruments spatiaux sur lesquels les
chercheurs ont travaillé qui ont fait le
succès des missions spatiales telles que
vénus express ou encore rosetta était
présente et 2019 marque aussi les 50 ans
du premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
les conférences et expositions
rencontres ont rassemblé toutes les
générations des animations en réalité
virtuelle avec la particularité d'avoir
été réalisé à partir de véritables
images collectées lors d'une mission
spatiale et un escape game à bord d'une
navette spatiale était proposé aux
visiteurs ils sont venus en nombre au
désespoir de certains on part du coup un
peu un peu déçu mais beaucoup beaucoup
de monde ça qu'on s'attendait pas à
autant de monde mais ça avait l'air ça
fait très intéressants dont c'est assez
dommage 1700 personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour découvrir face à
l'univers autre anniversaire aux
clayes-sous-bois l'espace philippe
noiret fête ses 10 ans cette année
saison particulière donc pour ce lieu
dont l ouverture de saison est prévue ce
samedi avec au programme expo goûter
soirée de présentation et spectacle
spécial et 10 ans au programme on en
parle avec vous
benjamin ball en bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur du développement
social et culturel aux clayes-sous-bois
alors l'espace philippe noiret c'est une
salle de spectacle des studios de
musique mais aussi un cinéma c'est
vraiment la vocation de cet équipement
de proposer diverses activités
culturelles
oui oui c'est à la fois bien sûr le
cinéma parce que ces deux salles dont
une toute nouvelle salle qui va rouvrir
samedi la petite salle qui était
complètement rénové voilà dans un design
vraiment très très confort c'est bien
sûr du théâtre de la musique c'est aussi
un espace où toutes les associations
aussi pratiquer leur art voilà ça soit
la partie musique à la partie théâtre
tout ce qui est lié à l'art plastique
voilà et puis c'est aussi un lieu
d'exposition puisque toute l'année le
hall du cinéma est réservé est
grandement aux expositions avec avec
toutes sortes d'expositions artistiques
ludiques voilà donc c'est c'est un
espace qui a déjà 10 ans voilà c'est
passé très très vite
quelques lits voilà de deux grands
artistes et puis des plus petits c'est
vraiment la vocation pluridisciplinaire
du lieu à paul vraiment voilà pôle
culturel de la ville ça représente quoi
justement pour la ville de fêter ses 10
ans bah c'est ça s'est passé très très
vite
voilà c'est un événement important parce
que c'est un c'est vraiment un lieu
central dans dans la ville des
clayes-sous-bois
voilà donc on est très heureux on a
préparé une belle soirée des belles
surprises voilà avec un spectacle qui
aura lieu sans lumière sur le bâtiment à
partir de 21h samedi et puis des
surprises artistiques parce que les
clayes-sous-bois sophie des artistes qui
commencent à être très connue je pense
aux deux comme ça george schmid qui a
vendu des millions d'albums dans le
monde et puis il dernier d'un sens vinel
voilà qu'avec a fait the voice et voilà
ils seront tous là pour célébrer aussi
que leur parcours artistique dans
lesquels sous bois on aura l'occasion de
présenter un cette journée festive il y
aussi des nouveautés de taille à l'une
des salles de cinéma qui a été refaite
ses seins refaits à neuf complètement
away dans une ambiance alors je ne veux
pas dévoiler le secret mais on s'est
inspiré d'un film un peu de philippe
noiret voilà qui s'appelle l'africain
donc elle va être dans une ambiance un
peu un peu spéciale en tout cas dans un
confort absolu avec une programmation
chaque semaine dans ce cinéma de
l'espace
philippe mentha fait nous avons deux
salles et voilà la programmation varie
toutes les semaines et on rouvre très
très prochainement la deuxième salle si
on parle de cette saison 2019 2020 qui
est lancée samedi à l'espace philippe
noiret ce que voilà on en avait parlé
juste avant les vacances une saison qui
est tournée sur vers l'humour vers les
hommages musicaux exactement l'humour et
les images musique ou le premier ça va
être le 4 octobre avec une magnifique
soirée autour d'yves montand
voilà avec un acteur pierre cassignard
qui est absolument incroyable a été
nominé plusieurs fois aux molières voilà
qu'il a eu aussi et qui nous raconte
comment il est venu au théâtre grâce à
yves montand c'est un hommage voilà
fabuleux il y aura un hommage à barbara
louise amstrong à l'ap la saison et qui
en humour on va on va pas en manquer
avec fabrice éboué entre autres enfin
voilà la saison va être va être riche
donc on voyait les spectateurs doivent
s'attendre à cette saison riche une fois
où j'ai vraiment ça va être une très
très belle saison avec aussi d'aider la
danse soit vraiment il ya je pense qu'il
ya de quoi trouver son son compte pour
les clés siens bien sûr mais aussi pour
pour les villes alentour samedi à partir
de 15h c'est le rendez vous à l'espace
il poussa appartient heures on a tué les
plus jeunes
voilà avec un
un goûter voilà une expo goûter ciné
goûter et puis après on a calé plus les
un peu plus anciens visite de la
nouvelle salle présentation de saison
sur scène
vernissage d'une très belle expo de
france trop autour de voix des acteurs
de cinéma tous les plus grands voilà
puisqu'elle était photographe dans tous
les grands festivals donc del mondo
ventura voilà qui sont photos des photos
uniques et puis après à 21h le spectacle
son et lumière avec des artifices sur
sur le bâtiment c'est à ne pas rater
mais pour réserver il faut réserver
avant d'en devenir vraiment gratuitement
toutes les informations sur le site des
quais souvent vous souhaite quoi juste
dernière question pour ses 10 ans on
souhaite dit dix prochaines années
magnifiques en termes de culture et de
de plaisir du spectateur
merci benjamin ball hand être venu
parler de ses 10 ans bon anniversaire à
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois et toutes les
informations à culturel 1 sont à
retrouver dans l'émission 7 8 culture
une émission bien sûr à retrouver juste
après ce journal sur tv 78 avant de se
quitter des cours pour de grands élèves
en jardinerie cette activité est la
dernière d'un cycle de formation au
jardinage proposé au parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
guen gonelle saintilan a suivi l'une de
ces formations
voici une salle de classe pour grand
jardinier
au programme une quinzaine de formation
étalée sur une année présentées par des
spécialistes de la nature insectes
plantes sauvages oiseaux et entretien de
son jardin tout est fait pour vous
apprendre à devenir un véritable éco
jardinier et maîtriser le cycle de vie
d'une plante est donc se passer de
produits chimiques
le 5 juillet dernier le parc naturel de
chevreuse invité jean marc rubens a
présenté le dernier atelier de ce cycle
de formation sur la taille des arbres
fruitiers
le centre d'initiation nature des eaux
baignères a accueilli ses grands
jardiniers en herbe pour discuter de la
taille en vert pommiers poiriers
noisetier ou encore cerisier 14
participants ont pu échanger pendant une
après-midi à propos des arbres fruitiers
de leur jardin
convivialité apprentissage ce sont des
formations à liancourt et travaux
pratiques pour devenir de vrais pros du
jardinage
j'ai pas un très très grand terrain donc
j'ai pas encore de vergers donc j'ai
débuté les greffes depuis deux saisons
pour démarrer des arbres l'objectif est
d'avoir un terrain peu plus grand dans
quelques années pour justement avoir un
verger
ok il ya un pommier poirier de cerisiers
et puis quelques un abricotier du jamais
lu un abricot depuis dix ans que je suis
et puis pas mal de pruniers ces ateliers
pratiques sont des moments de partage
d'astuces et de méthode entre
particuliers j'ai mieux habitués ou
novices chacun pourra appliquer les
méthodes de retour dans son jardin
les participants sont heureux d'en
apprendre un maximum et n'attendent
qu'une chose d'autres formations à bas
au dessus de l'oeil blacks comme ça les
ures du coup au dessus de l'oeil plat
pour celle pour la bonne et simple
raison si vous faites ça vous élève
jardiniers et spécialistes de la nature
on vous attend donc nombreux pour le
prochain c'est que deux formations
l'année prochaine c'est la fin de ce
journal belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]